good afternoon everyone
thank you for joining us for another
live podcast webinar I hope you're all
well hope your families are healthy and
we're getting through this together so
thank you for joining us where we're
going to start is to do some
introductions however I just wanted to
help you all out in terms of how you can
engage with the great panelists that we
have today so there's a few ways that
we're going to do this today so that the
first one it's going to be and using the
Q&A section which some of you already
using so and Joe Stacy's putting
afternoon Hisham if we can basically use
that Q&A section and for all of you guys
to submit questions and then that's
where you want to put your questions as
we're going through this and if there's
questions that you really like and what
people submit then what you can do is
click up vote like I just have on Jack
priors and point there then we're going
to make sure that we get those questions
answered that's the first thing and then
what we're going to do shortly after the
panelists have introduced themselves and
we're gonna do a very quick poll and
just to help us understand the panelists
understanding exactly who's attending
today to make sure that all of you get
as much value out of this webinar as
possible so if we start with
introductions Sandra if you go first and
let everyone know a bit about you and
then we can go onto marason Nick yeah hi
everyone I'm Sanjay Patel Stewart and
CEO and Founder transition partners and
I founded the business in 2011 we
recruit permanent and contract across
technology digital and business
transformation uk-wide based in Leeds
and we've got 19 staff and a couple of
years ago or just under two years ago we
set up operations in Germany in Berlin
and why we only recruit tech
amazing Thank You Sandra Nick if you go
next so I work for a comic called Mac
darlin company my title is partnership
director and in the UK we got 65
consultants and 120 around the world
cool and your sector is real estate and
property and your perm recruits on you
predominate perm yeah I'm cool and last
but not least Marius yes hi guys this is
Marius from SR 2 stands for a socially
responsible recruitment where I just
over two years old I can I'd see
recruitment start recruit across the
software development lifecycle mainly UK
contracts and perm similar sign we've
also just out recruiting in Berlin as
well okay cool
and anything just to add to the context
of that Maris you manager of small team
as well then here yeah it's like people
hi people and then Sandra's you see your
brand founders who are managing people
in your business at the moment and then
Nick your hand got the luxury of
managing a team of you know so I handed
back to my team most months ago yeah
sort of sole responsible for new
business cool so what we're gonna do now
guys is I'm gonna submit a very quick
poll and this is just going to help us
understand exactly who's joining us
today
so the first one which all of you should
and appear for you now which is how
experienced are you if you could let us
know exactly how experienced you are and
while I'm doing that I'm gonna ask these
guys some questions and then this can
help give them some context for when we
think about answers but the first thing
that should set the scene guys and how
how the last couple of days been what's
been going on in your worlds
I'm happy to kick off so I'd say so I'd
said what I'm finding maybe over the
last few days is that companies have
almost I guess accepted the fact that
like Kobe 19 is here to stay for the
foreseeable and there doesn't need to be
a bit of a change in terms of how we do
things and there seems to be a lot of
content on LinkedIn and a lot of content
out there so it's talking about hiring
processes and an onboarding and I think
clients are starting to kind of buy into
that except that
so I'd say it kind of dropped off
drastically but I'd say now in terms of
like adverts I'm seeing and class I'm
speaking to albeit it's still quiet I
think the market is improving yeah we're
like a small amount I think I've
definitely found people moving into this
sort of acceptance mindset where as few
a couple of weeks ago is very much
watching the news what's going on how
things gonna change it cetera how have
you guys won underneath we certainly
over the last kind of three or four days
actually and found that things are
starting to settle down and the
conversations that I've been having the
clients and candidates more you know
everyone's kind of got into their
routines and it's more like you see that
acceptance stage now yeah we had like
most most businesses we've probably had
about 80 85 percent of our work drop off
and we've been quite looking with a
couple of clients if kind of captures
moving really and so we've actually last
three or four days we've with I think
we've closed about three or four office
we are motor I'm certainly finding that
things are starting to start down a
little bit albeit who knows what's gonna
happen in the next few weeks Nick
anything to our door as Adam very
similar with this week the honeymoon
period is over I think for roads and and
everyone at home so that there is
definitely appeared with getting used to
it getting back into their routine so
we're hopefully some of those decisions
going to move forward to recruitments
pretty soon but we've been surprised
that there are still pockets of activity
so just like sundar said you know we had
a massive sort of pause of activity
immediately a shock reaction but what
happens in the next two three four weeks
it's going to be really interesting okay
cool
so just to give you guys context so 39
people with us today have got over five
years experience and three to five year
experience 13 and then the rest of the
people fall into this sort of one-year
to father your category and so the final
poll guys which is just going to really
help us and with this is it's just going
to be really worth as knowing if you're
currently on furlough war or working I
think that's gonna be really useful for
us to know when we're talking about
how these guys are adapting obviously
Mario Sandra and Nick are very much
still working and but I'm just I've just
opened up that pond it'd be great for
Lupita now I mean the majority of people
that responded already yeah I mean
everyone pretty much everyone with us
today guys are still working they are in
the trenches right and this is why I
wanted you guys on because you guys are
still very much in the trenches having
to rise to the occasion and and weather
this storm so I guess just just for
everyone's benefit I know you just
touched on it a bit there but like how
am i % egde wise what we talking in
terms of live jobs being dropped so like
what what you got what the current
opportunities for you guys to set the
scene for everyone what does that
currently look like so son what did you
say we've probably in about 85 to 90
percent fall fee okay is that I know
Nick we were talking before is about 80
percent for you and something like
easily 80 percent media yeah in gays
yeah and then thankfully the past two
weeks then we've seen then a sever those
clients moved from being on some freeze
to moving forward yeah okay cool now yes
what about UFC contract recruiter so
obviously in terms of new new
opportunities and new projects yeah I
mean I would say there hasn't been a lot
of stuff that's been like pulled by I'd
say like in terms of actual maybe like
our bigger clients that were giving us
and lots and lots of jobs and we're very
active before there's a few of those
that just like completely start ok yeah
ok cool so look the first question on
ask before we go into and the audience's
questions that some of the ones that
people submitted is what have you guys
found most challenging so far what what
has been really difficult for you so far
in the last couple of weeks since this
has been going on um so as personally or
as a business to you evil
at that month okay and I've got two
volleys and I'm a mum I've got a four
and a half year old and my husband
wouldn't own owns a recruitment business
as well luckily is in the health care
industry so he's been pretty busy and
but the problem that we've had and where
I struggled is for his both managing
working
at the same time I'm keeping us on
entertained so when the first two three
days we were literally at loggerheads my
I thought I was going to grill it what
what's been like what really happens
through that really helped and together
works and we leach me like have like two
three-hour blocks throughout the day
where one of us will be working or not
be looking after my son and I mean I'm
having to do more in the evenings but
you know don't really mind I've done
that quite a bit in the past and to be
fair let's face it wouldn't really got
anything to do with okay calm what was
it what's been the second challenge and
I would say is and which I think we've
done a lot of good stuff around this and
I'm happy to talk about this in more
detail later on and is motivating the
people and I think going back to your
new questions and rambles development I
think have encouraging and supporting
and motivating the people is just
anyone's like cater to business
development right now okay cool so we'll
definitely dive into that but definitely
been a challenge to making sure that
your guys are motivated up for it okay
cool what about you Nick what was what's
been the most challenging for you so far
so personally likes like Sundra dealing
with children at home and sharing an
office with you why what would your wife
did she will create financial services
okay so she shouts at me for being too
noising her phone I shout at her because
she types really angrily so yes it's
just there's no real escape from work
now is this there's no office there's no
commute to break it all up so that's
that's what both struggled with the past
couple of weeks how do you feel how have
you found switching off sorry just to
jump in there cuz that's I've definitely
found that hard I don't think we have so
the linear the laptop yeah that's 24/7
so will you know we'll do something in
the morning while someone's making
breakfast and then we'll go back and
then equally you know bedtime comes and
then you got you know you'll check it
before you go to bed so yeah it's got
stew
switching off it's very different but
then we can't I can't work a solid nine
or eight hours a day so you got a
compensate yeah cool
Marius what's been the most challenging
for you I'd say pretty similar to
sandwich I think putting like a
motivation point of view at the team
we've like put together like some small
incentives that we can run but we might
be having some like good wins throughout
the day and then we've had a few cases
where people we've recently placed have
been given like notice for example and
you've got a new consultant who's just
done a few deals and he's been told that
fearless guys are like a few weeks in
they're just obviously going off site
where it's like a six month project mmm
so I'd say I guess just trying to manage
that and motivate people and when
they're having conversations with
candidates and who have pain in quite a
bleak picture in the market it's like
and you're not sat next them you can't
have that kind of conversation or coffee
with them how'd you I guess keep them
motivated in like just kind of
management rate period is for the
trickiest okay so just very quickly
Jeremy's asked an absolutely crack of a
question which and asked in the sec but
just just quickly as we're talking about
managing teams I wanna make sure that we
touched on it because I feel like a lot
of conversations I'm having and some of
the questions that come through that's
been a common challenge but and what's
been the sort of thing that you've done
so far that's been the most impactful
one the motivational team do you think
has it been other than I have in the
morning stand up all the time or doing
open and right the transition partner
zoom pub on Friday I don't know what
what what from your boy field
perspectives what's been the most what's
had the most impact on my vet in your
team's the team might disagree and I
mean obviously we do in a lot of zooms
and I'm trying to have as much
one-on-one contact with the guys where I
can and as well I think I think
initially when they saw kicked off the
one thing that we did was we said right
we're gonna take away personal targets
individual targets for now they're all
going to drug kpi's and I tried to take
the pressure off them as much as
possible
mmm for the next cortex would probably
eat looks is looking like it's gonna be
almost a full chorus is right for the
next quarter
we looked at what everybody's tuck if we
added all the titles together what that
would look like we reduced it 50% or
something like that and we're just in
fact we're gonna have a team target and
all right so we're all basically working
together as one big team I mean it's
easier for us to do that because there's
only 19 of us yeah so we're all working
together as one big team we get a role
in we've got more than one pet want more
than one consultant working that role
and and between the consultants they
agree their approach how they work huge
was what who does job causality next
subject
between them they agree on splits and
things like that and and I think that
and then have you trained have you
change about the Commission structure
and if like that or is there yeah it's
not ready okay yeah in Christ then
Marius what about you what's been really
impactful I think it's hard to say like
one like one particular thing but I'd
say a few things we've done we've done
like the zoom stand-ups in like the
morning and lunchtime we've done like
virtual that pub quiz for example and I
grab one together to do that which is
quite nice then we've also said from
like a contract perspective like where
we might find quite strict verticals
before just to free it up a little bit
and if you've got behind so you've got
good relationships with you've placement
before and you're good engagement then
you can work on my permanent positions
as well okay so just I guess freeing up
those rules a little bit and just trying
to really share the wins as well yeah
yeah what they can focus on yeah yeah
okay yeah let's get to this Jeremy's
questioning because I think that has an
absolute cracker like if you if you guys
could go back in time six months know
that Co vid Christ was going to happen
what would you change your business
practices to be better protected that's
what great question what comes to mind
from people from that and maybe like
this sector like focusing on is probably
see this like six months ago then you
may be like you're a acardo's you're
like Tesco Sainsbury's all these like
retail they've got online shopping
platforms if you could wrap all those
guys up imagine they just get busier and
busier yeah I mean every you know so
secretary nurses
yeah okay that's interesting
Nick what do you think because I think
obviously you for you to start I'll see
you in the real estate world right
inside like what comes to mind for you
and when we look at Jeremy's question
it's a really tough question because if
we think about this is like another
recession you know what what would you
do to really sort of steal yourself
through you chord like my Maris said you
could look at other sectors but
ultimately think you want to make sure
that all the basics are in place the
team's gelling nicely in animation
sharing freely there is a really strong
incentive about building and developing
client relationships I'm fortunate I
think a lot of that was already in place
which is go do a little bit more of it
now yeah no I really like that I think
what what what we discussed in a
previous podcast on here was I think a
lot of recruiters going into this
potentially have laid their bed like if
there was something that wasn't too
bored about relations what was really
quite transactional and to really start
forming these relationships and doubling
down on those and built the new
relations can be even more difficult
right so I guess that's part of what
you're touching on there Nick and one of
the questions that I wanted to just sort
of expand on that which came from a chat
could Jake major and was sort of what
your guys tips for progressing
transactional relationships through this
period to more meaningful ones right now
how can people go about and to start
forming meaningful relationships
I'll say that one so a transactional
relationship as it suggests is you know
it's about transaction it's about
providing a service that fits that fits
the right time for the right price well
now we've got an opportunity to improve
those by just being a lot more personal
mmm we're seeing each other in our in
our bedrooms in our lounges or kitchen
rooms so you know talking about people's
kids you know what they've been up to
so yeah it's actually
lotty easier to build relationships
everything right now because we've got a
lot more in common
mmm so focusing on on that focusing on
on how you're developing those
relationships by making sure they see
you as a person thinks me really
important okay anything else to add guys
to that when one of the things that that
I've been doing in some of our guys have
been doing that face out to clients and
he's offering different services okay so
I guess some of its not different
services in that offering just just
making our network no and our clients
and candidates know that we are out here
we're here to support we're here to help
everyone we're all in the same boat and
so we've put together and I've been
sending out as a CEO I've been sending
out to all our clients anyone that we've
ever had terms in place with and I've
been sending out a newsletter and an
email offering just reminding them what
services that we can offer but also
offering things like I've been offering
training and free webinars to internal
recruitment teams awesome and I've been
asked we've been offering CV mo T's
andmy
branding for LinkedIn and because we do
a lot online we do a lot around and
podcasts and videos and ensuring that
all our LinkedIn posts and things like
Aaron brand yeah and it's been offering
and help to help you know candidates
client we Brandon we were Tim profiles
and our placement opportunities and help
him with their load team's spiritual
client yesterday actually for about half
an hour and that was a client him
initially and didn't put their equipment
on hold but they were consultancy so
fortunately over the last week or two
they've realized that they need to
they've got people on the bench now so
they've had to put the equipment on hold
and from when I spoke to him about my
news item and then I followed up with an
email and sent him the newsletter and he
said actually got some of that might
come in useful and he said some of our
business dev guys my benefit from a bit
of training and a bit of support or not
new and so it's just I guess it's just
getting that out there and getting the
support out there in the personal
element out there building and cement in
those relationships so our clients
candidates senior candidates they know
that in two three months time when
things change and we're all back you
know we're at you know battered to full
kind of full steam ahead that they'll
remember what you did for them or what
you tried to do for them and I think
that's important right you know that's a
key to some of your services haven't
been more on services to monetize but
more to pay it forward give real value
which will end here might even set and
like if a client and has a role that's
not within our secretary and that we've
got the stuff we've got the capacity and
capability to deliver them we'll do it
at highly reduced fee ok payroll finance
HR any office admin type position and
just to help them out and you know we
all need everyone needs help right now
don't they it's not really not kind of
community and support where we can Nick
Maurice have you I don't know over the
last couple of weeks or so we've seen
opportunities to deliver value if that's
for a service or not a service have you
guys done anything that yeah is a
slightly different approach in some of
the services that you can offer for
clients and candidates that's helped me
night I'd say one it's like quite
specific consultant seeds we support
consultancies like obviously when they
win the work but sometimes when they're
actually like putting together teams for
four bids in almost providing like a bit
of a virtual bench and consultancy is
there a bit smaller that might want to
bid for large pieces of work it in my
the public sector they might know the
capacities that I provide the team
upfront so we can basically put together
like a mock team if you like and they
can represent that's the client and if
the clients comfortable with that they
might say I'm happy to give you the work
and at that point we comes to help them
fill the roles that's something we've
done for a while but quite like a nice
value add and if they further people the
bench maybe it's not as strong as you
slayers we can give them the opportunity
what about you Nick have you seen any
opportunities
so similar to Sandra about deepening
relationships working with people who
you enjoy working with already so I'm
instead of broadening the roles you
might have considered before or might
want to add value to but also around
whilst these clients are getting to
testing themselves on video interviewing
people don't trust it yet they feel very
unfamiliar so everything from helping
them get set up yeah Roo to maybe
offering different ways to assess so
using personality and psychometric
testing so that these clients can then
have another layer of testing another
laying of assessment so that they feel
comfortable making a hiring decision
without having ever met so more yeah
well that's really interesting so I
guess what I'd love to sort of segue
this into because I think this ties
quite nicely into it is one of the most
popular questions that people submitted
effli around business development and so
I guess like one of the questions that
was put through by enough annual Smith
which was what methods of is development
do people feel is best suited to the
current situation I guess some of the
things that you're touching on Sandra
which I've been speaking to about
there's been effective is leading with
hey mr. and mrs. crying we're running
this webinar doing this it's a lot of
people that have some of challenges I'd
like to think you'd find it useful how
old would you be to get involved
whatever that the neighborhood's have
some good business element activity but
how how how are your guys approaching it
and what what you find them that's
working on helping weave weave them
Samia you stood before pivot 19 weeks we
used to do a lot of them meetups and
moving about 25 to 30 a year ago we had
I think probably about three or four
books in that we have to counsel yeah
and so in the last week or two and we've
started setting them up so that we can
run them virtually and saying with
regard to here we've set up and myself
and Ellie greenie one of the other
directors and we've been running the wit
podcast which they helped us with yeah
yeah yeah going on that and I'm so we'd
set up a leadership podcast and go sea
level
and smoke holders and so we decided to
just keep running with that as well we
just thought well and we can't do it
face to face but like why does it have
to stop so and so how as I hope new
avenues and that's really helped me I
reached out to a CIO of quite a
decent-sized technology business either
week we've got booked in in a couple of
weeks
another consultancy that we've been
trying to make inroads in with for some
time and we're doing the podcast with
them and we got one of the owners next
week and that's working and what we've
said to our guys is I'm licensed
actually you want me to die on a zoom
meeting with our guys I said look you
will we'll put the email together
welcome you all the information and the
branding or you literally all you need
to do is put target listed companies
together a crutch see the sea level the
guys at the table book the podcasting
will do the rest we get business now on
that further down the line that's your
client and natural be doing awesome
smart
mariusz what are you then what are you
finding that's working
so I'd say against it since and we've
done like a leaders in tech meets up in
Bristol and London and that historically
has been really helpful in terms like
building relationships with key
stakeholders having like a different
reason to approach them but I'd say now
I think for me it's just about trying to
be like quite smart with the way the
approach business development so I do
not quite a lot of stuff in the public
sector and there's that with information
available online basically outlines all
if they're
suspend in the sector because going
actually look at all of the companies
that one work recently what they've won
the kind of teams they're gonna need to
build that's all publicly available so
then the cons you call in your feeling
where that they've gone recruit x y&z
and your spins people that regardless of
coma 19 or not they've committed to
delivering sent things so I guess it's
almost like less is more and
just trying to target the business
development or clients they know are
going to be busy in the climate
regardless and everything else that's
going on smart and the only other thing
I say is trying to be a bit more like
your recruitment consultant be quite
consultative so instead of thinking
quite narrow mind
just like about a single job you want to
be trying to think about the business as
a whole and think you're speaking to a
CTO if he's furloughed his team if he's
got deliverable what's he committed to
just trying to think the business is
more of a whole whole whole picture and
understand the company's problems and
then based on that you might be able to
identify opportunities they're not my
actual job role which might be I'd sell
contracts and everything else I think
just trying to think of it like more
commercially with all yeah
smart Nick what about you because
obviously you're in a position which is
completely focused on developing
relationships business development so
what what you find them that's working
for you Nick besides staying in touch
with existing clients and these types of
things
what you said you say apart from that's
it real secret to which people will be
really singer and there will be people
who'll be successful throughout this and
they'll be stronger know this artist is
the people who build the really really
strong relationships for those clients
and candidates mmm so to answer your
question you know I think sort of what
we do to explain to people who haven't
been through tough times before who've
only been recruiting maybe last two or
three years is you need to change your
mindset about what you're looking to get
out of this if you get the idea of
making making five telephone calls and
on the third one I'll pick up a job
right right now York your target is to
speak to as many people as possible
learn as much from every call you can
forget about if you think they're a
client or a candidate you want to find
out market information you know what's
happening their organization are they
are they contracting are they growing
what areas are are improving and then
keep building this up and keep talking
to colleagues to share this information
and the free that information flows the
much easier it is then to develop that
client base so change the expectations
of what a successful business develops
like is going to be really key to help
and I think that's obviously what you
just touched on as well merit isn't that
in terms just be more commercially
minded then yeah absolutely yeah yeah so
um so I'm gonna and so sorry for
pronounce your name wrong
Tunisia apology if that's wrong but
really interesting question there I
think safe to say the businesses
that you have been speaking to you have
been reducing costs etc so the question
would be good to get your thoughts on is
would reduce numbers of active jobs
roles getting on hold the role of an
agency recruiter is gonna become more
challenging which accompanies tending to
cut on costs and count on internal
recruiters what what you guys don't try
and ensure that I guess that sort of
your service and what you do remains
really valuable so what do you think
about that I personally I think to vent
and internal recruiters that their role
is getting tougher as really businesses
sort of bring down the volume of hiring
I think I think they are they're very
more risk of being on furlough because
suddenly it's easier just to use a
consultant to support you on on a much
smaller number there's a lot less
farming that's needed by an internal
recruiter so I think keep keep really
close to all your relationships but
there are internal recruitment HR line
managers c-suite whatever may will be
and I think that will hold you in really
good stead interesting and if in SATs
that guys may I tell maybe look at the
clients you've had like your
relationships with historically and if
they are maybe smaller companies that
are struggling with cash flow for
example and their last needs reduced
fees I think it's one try and be
pragmatic and if the good rules of
engagement are there and if you know
they're gonna pay in the long run and
they've made about history of you
working together then I think it's
definitely worth exploring creative
solutions and maybe that's an
opportunity to have a conversation a
segue into more exclusivity and
everything else good rules of engagement
you said that couple of times what do
you mean by that
so I'd say for me like I think now it's
time to maybe worry about like the
volume of jobs you have a bit less and
more about local and the quality of the
jobs yeah I mean if you've got ten jobs
that with a big pierce-arrow and you're
dealing with the port when you have
really got much opportunity speed to
line managers is obviously almost it's
quite your percentages of filling the
role quite low whereas even got a client
you place number of people with and you
understand the business and you have
direct contact and managers for me I'd
rather have me one or two of those jobs
than 1015 jobs there just sat in the
portal so I think maybe I tend to find
the clients we've got good hit Ray's
good ratios and
spending more time of those nice okay
you know I think there's probably a
couple of different options that you
could look at and I mean one one
actually that you touched on earlier a
chemise around and payment you know come
consider like like married sit have a
conversation pick up a conversation with
them and there's different options
things that you can discuss like
potential payment plans and you could
ask them to commit and agree to an SLA
for a reduction in fee so if you are
having to reduce the fees and I would
just you know kind of remember that
we're all in the same boat here we're
all trying to survive and so you know
try and come up with a compromise that's
fair because doing that now will stand
you in good stead longer term and you'll
be remembered for that look things pick
up and there's volume recruitment there
you've more likely to get that on an
exclusive basis and payment plans or
even retainers as well as the part of
the fee upfront and we'll see you'll
reduce the fee if you can have say 25
percent on engagement and and split it
into chunks
throughout the process sure I think this
goes quite nicely into Sobeys question
around I mean I think I'm sure you've
all seen it people offering free
services these types of things like what
were your guys thoughts on offering free
recruitment services and placing people
for free what do you think about that I
think I've value their kind of service
you offer in Southie I wouldn't say you
want to be doing stuff for free cuz I
imagine if they've got customers then
I'll not be doing stuff for free there
and either so I'd say I'd say like again
you can try me prime Matic and if that's
the conversation that there may be like
teeing up then you can like Sandra said
talk about payment plan or talk about
maybe some slightly different
arrangement that is more like cost
effective to them but I think if you're
recruiting for free then the I think
it's got about the value time bit more
yeah for sure and what I'd like to get
some of your thoughts on because I had
quite a few questions around
this just around basically just it's
been really effective and how your days
have changed and sort of working out
what you should be prioritizing I've had
other things so one of the questions I
got from Joe Bunji hopefully I
pronounced your surname right it was how
has your day plan changed as a result of
this what new activities are you
planning into your week what do you
think about that and might got simpler
okay it's a lot of outbound activity
it's a lot a lot more telephone calls
and listen listening really really
listening to what's what's going on and
because often that will inform then what
happens whether it's that afternoon or
later that week or later that month so
we have we have a lot less strategy
meetings a lot less internal meetings
now which is one one nice plus yeah and
it's just it's just got a lot a lot
simpler okay interested Mary Sandra I'm
saying and certainly for the guys that
are kind of more hands-on and I guess
we've got quite a lot of the creatures
on here that probably in that one year
one to five year kind of bucket and he's
he's he's been on the phones a lot more
and I've certainly experienced we some
of our guys they've never had to work in
a market where you haven't where you
haven't been calling a candidate about
the job so they're now having to call
candidate when they don't really have
anything to offer them and and I think I
think some of our guys and a lot of the
recruiters that are still working have
struggled with that and certainly our
daily activities have changed more
towards um working through our database
working through all those candidates at
the moment that Owens stable and sure
about their role or they had any mold
before all this started and they've all
been retracted and so we certainly we're
certainly spending a lot more time on
the phone speaking to candidates a look
looking for work out with a lot of
contractors and relevant if you're
finding that Mary's a lot of contact
and move out of work yeah so just trying
to do everything we can for our
candidates really okay
merit anything to add what what what
have sort of become the non-negotiables
for you in your day plans
I'd say points being more like client
focused I think whereas before maybe I
spent a lot of time as a contract
recruit said like speaking to candidates
trying to get leads trying to find out a
lot of information like so I know said
if you haven't got lots of the acting
jobs to speak to people about and the
kind of outlook is quite bleak then it
seems quite it's quite tough exercise to
do so I'd say yeah be more client
focused and I think I just makes it
before but just trying to think about
like the data like 535 lot off payroll
for example they keep posting list of
all companies that have basically got
rid of those contracts 535 and now
they've got Highland back in again maybe
you're just trying to think outside the
box a little bit and think you know
there's a great list of people I should
be calling because they are gonna now
have to hire people yeah so yeah so so
um Nick let me start a view on this so I
was having this conversation the other
day so as you were saying your day
planner come a lot more simpler the lot
of outbound calls speak to people
listening blah blah blah how are you
dealing with like you know being a good
recruiter and for dinner how long you
been doing it for you will know that
typically the outputs are you're putting
putting in right now will typically lead
to X outcome right and I'm sure that the
outputs you're putting in now because of
the climb out because of the landscape
what's going on you're not getting the
outcomes that you may expect or that you
would have got let's say a couple of
months ago whatever so mentally how how
are you dealing with that cuz I feel
like a lot of people going through that
people will try and even more or I
haven't make more phone calls and now
I've had before having to do these
things putting in the output but they're
not getting now see that the outcomes
that they were typically again that can
be quite a struggle to deal with that so
that how how have you been dealing with
that and I don't know anything to add on
that I don't have any real deep and
meaningful answer for you conversion
numbers have gone right down yeah the
way which we've handled it is we've got
a good news what's that channel
Nine's yeah I think we all sometimes
need a bit of reassurance or a passing
aback when when something goes our way
and you know a few months ago that might
have been doing a deal right now so the
good news counters having a really
positive call making up a lead you know
having having then sort of a bit of a
bit of industry knowledge then to pick
up and go and come through so as I
mentioned before the target of what
you're looking to get out of each call
has changed but the buzz of getting
positivity is it hasn't changed we still
want that reassurance we still want that
sort of recognition and so it's up to
business leaders and companies tend to
to make sure they're there to to room to
recognize that yes a celebration may be
the a couple of months ago would be
thinner smaller winds but having a place
where you can celebrate those yeah
that's also one it's one step along that
that journey you know the more
information you collect the more leads
the more positive clients and right
through to year we've had an exercise
recently on some boosting sort of
testimonials we all know how important
these are with you know we've all got a
handful across our website across our
branding but right now so real times
getting social dough the clients who you
have done a great job with pasture 212
mothers saying right now it's the time I
could really do with that help would you
mind then give me give me something for
that and whether it's on LinkedIn or
whether it's off offline now's the time
than to be asking yeah I love that
that's amazing
saundra anything to I because I think
that's quite interesting to get your
thoughts on that we use slack and and
we've got we've very similar and key
really making that we you know any I
guess what's considered now as a as a
positive or big witness you know even
things like like you say like a positive
conversation or lead and you know it's
like we're all celebrating here and and
I think the main thing is he's looking
he's supporting the people and helping
them with their mindset it's a mindset
thing so we've been doing things like
we've obviously having daily morning and
some looks like zoo meetings and we've
got a coach that we've always that we've
used for about six months
Tony cookers
he may may know of her and she said
she's been helping us out tremendously
she's been doing one-to-one coaching
with the guys and we've been I've been
contacting some really decent like
there's a lot of trainers out there that
are offering free training yeah
absolutely loving that and it's just I
think ensuring that the people are happy
then breathe and and that mindset and
keeps a movie that you can keep some
cracking on and hammering the phones as
much as they can and even simple things
like yesterday I mean the sun's been out
all week has nothing yesterday and they
were all chatting on the slack about the
sunshine at lunchtime and I said you
know I said guys crack on solidly for
two hours focus and you can all finish
it form go and enjoy the sunshine yeah
and I just think things like that no
matter how many not much you get I would
if you like I would our guys our team
the team were all really really pulling
together and and you know and overcoming
those obstacles as best we can and we're
doing it together and do you think do
you think did you think your business
has got closer Yeah right yeah external
mmm yeah not true for a lot of
businesses at the moment I think I think
I think there's gonna be a lot of
positives actually that come out of this
moving forwards I think a lot more
businesses will be open-minded to home
working and flexibility and you'll be
more trustworthy as well actually and I
think there'll be a lot of positive
changes that come out of things what do
we think will be some of the well I had
a question for you from and Ryan Jase
well apologies if that pronounce that
surname wrong but like what do you think
just on that like coming out of this the
other side of this how what do we think
some of the challenges will be for
recruiters when we're sort of bouncing
back and into the market probably not to
get complacent hmm they that we've been
forced into this situation no one to
chose and miss it situation
so we are all adapting because because
of that and what we don't want to do is
go back to some old habits if you were a
junior recruiter whereby some of your
relationships were quite shallow and
your your next but in the next few
months maybe longer
about trying to develop those don't
forget that when you go when you do when
we are opening offices back when we are
going back to what we think was you know
what used to be considered normal and
make sure you continue that attitude of
just treating just how important these
these relationships are and building on
those mm-hmm I like that that's really
don't get complacent - anything to add
what do you think will be some of the
challenges bouncing back out of this I'd
say yeah I think don't get complacent
some really good one maybe a more like
personal level if people hadn't been out
left outside the house for like three
months and then they've got come back
into recruitment maybe where it's not
been number one priority I dunno so just
a quick and just a quick one and I think
just to build on I think Madison
Sandri was saying about definitely
noticing that a lot more cabinets out of
work these sorts of things so one of the
questions that actually David submitted
which was how are you approaching
conversation with candidates that are
wanting something immediate but the
opportunity is that a live aren't
suitable for them I'm sure you might be
having a lot of these conversations
where a lot of these candidates can't
help them so like how other night how
you managing that cuz I'm sure there's a
lot more of that going on
I mean I've and I've been having
conversations with concerts and
Dimetrodon I don't get involved at that
level anymore and although I do always
try me from the third and so I'm quite
still quite hands-on and the
conversations I've been here I've just
been very open and honest yeah I've been
really really openness about what works
bathing scene and the drop off rate of
roles you know which of our clients are
still hiring but unfortunately there's
you know there's a limited and reduced
number of roles available and and what I
said to them is whether it's been a
conversation over LinkedIn of look I'm
more than happy to speak to you and have
a conversation
see if I can help you in any way shape
or form and if I'm on the phone to them
I've been saying you know I'm more than
happy to help me with his CV see if
there's anything that could do with a CV
link timber well why don't you write a
post or I can write a post for you and
if I if we do a quick interview now and
then I'll put a post together that sells
you and you experience and what you've
done and I'll post it to my network
colleagues to share it and to a lot of
our guys have been doing the same with
candidates we've been sharing profiles
about looking for working out of work we
offered to speak to our contacts and
networks just to see if there's anything
that they can help them with and
obviously you know there could be some
free placements that sit through there
but the end of the day I'd rather do
what we can do to support those guys
that you know they're what we've all got
families we've all got or the mouths to
feed and families to support we all need
to survive yeah I think it's about
creating that community fuel helping
each other and Joe I spoke to a be a
contractor in in Milton Keynes you're
the day and I be honest I've got no
chance in hell finally no rollin and
placing her by spirit for like 15
minutes and she's on her own as well
living on her own and she just meeting
the appreciate having a chat with me
yeah and I just look I'm happy to do a
post VA and you know I'm gonna write my
own book we'll look at it before I post
it so I have a look at it changed it
around a bit for her she posted it and
then she sent me the link and I shared
it to my network it's just been an open
and doing what you can I guess -
anything to add to that or is it have
you been sort of having similar
conversations yeah I think similar
conversations I think hand is a bit more
in concern when you're thinking about
certain positions maybe like to spend a
bit more time my tailor in their CV and
like writing cover sheets and maybe
doing a bit of coaching around making
them like just just maximizing
opportunities to gauge role and I think
also maybe like pointing them in the
direction of companies that you're not
it may be engage whether you're not in
the PSL but you know they are hiring so
they'll come back around if you can help
them you know yeah
yeah those people that you can't
necessarily helping the shorts I'm just
trying to do your part because that that
would be remembered is a good way yeah
well what about I mean Louise Gilmore's
question and also Tunisia is maybe knit
you can add some of this what you've
been hearing from your guys internally
but what about on the perm side I feel
like that could be more difficult right
there there will be a lot of people that
will be very cautious and uncertain
about moving jobs in this time should
like what like should people on a
permanent basis like be moving right now
like how are you approaching that
because I feel like a lot of people will
think or assume that yeah they don't
want to move but it's not the right
thing to do like how are you never
getting free that because I'm sure that
can be a real challenge for a lot of
people right now on the firm side gonna
attend I tend to find that candidates am
more bullish than employers so I think
the majority kind of so I supply speak
to our less concerned about that they
still feel this is a very short-term
okay dip and so the problems they might
have been facing all the difficulties
they might been facing in their current
role probably still exist they might
have gone on hold and but they they
don't feel that they're learning or they
don't feel they're developing later
they're paid correctly whatever may
won't be yes exists so yeah having those
honest conversations with them but
really against the bottom up what they
want to change no holds true asked as to
how long it will take to for you to sort
of to make a change for them no one
knows that right now today yeah but I
would encourage them to embrace the
situation and go along to a handful of
video interviews it's never been easier
to go to an interview right yeah and
learn what else might be out there and
open up your eyes to how other
organizations ticks and how they might
be handling certain situations and it
can only be a positive processor that's
interesting so what you're saying Nick
is that those sort of motivations to
want to leave or why maybe initially
being speaking see Pete there they still
very much exist and it's just making
sure that those candidates on the poem's
side of just getting even more clarity
and I guess just thinking a bit deep in
it because this is that I think that's
I'd like to think that people are also
taking the opportunity right now they're
gonna have to really think about or
getting the opportunity to think about
their career what they're doing are they
enjoying what they're doing and these
sorts of things you know I mean so
that's interesting Sondra what you found
the knee of yourself or with your guys
on the sort of perm side how are they
approaching it
yeah I'm similar to Nick really we have
things to people advantages recently
actually and I've been concerned about
moving and that you know their wives
have obviously been speaking to them
about their concerns and and so we the
the recent situation we had I just think
you know what like speak to speak
clearly and in any way in any climate
and but one thing that has worked was
recently reading that direct engagement
going between the client and the
candidate we are encouraging the
candidate to speak to the client
directly about their future plans their
growth strategy in three and doing your
own research on the industry in the
client as well so and you know there are
going to be some sequences of had cut
the kite but some candidates that have
said you know what I don't want to leave
my team in the lurch right now I'm
really interested in the opportunity we
don't go for it I want to wait until all
this is over I don't know be situations
where like you can't really do a lot
about it but then I guess just see that
as youth pipelining future on mass use
fall off your chair guys lots of in cool
so I guess look as we solve come towards
the end of this and let's just talk a
bit about what what were you're thinking
about how this is planning now like what
what's the current I mean we've been in
what in the UK is coming to like the
third week isn't that in terms of sort
of lock down so I guess I think the
businesses that I'm speaking to you
recruiters on speaking to I mean they're
reviewing us on a week week by week
basis maybe in daily basis but what are
our current
sort of forts towards where this is
going and how it's going to plan out
what do you think I know no one knows
but what's the current thought process I
think you bet for the long-term that
what we disappoint it well as it would
you mean by that's alright
I don't think this is going to end
anytime soon
yeah and any change it won't be a an
immediate turning back of the clock and
everyone starts commuting back for all
sectors I think probably the advice we
give internally is you know
let's assume we're in this along long
haul and if it ends sooner than that
well where we all be pleasantly
surprised
mmm Marius what how what are you
thinking about it's hard says no I think
reading the news it it's it's pretty
depressing really yeah and you hear so
many mixed views in terms of when a lot
of sounds going to end and when it's all
going to come back to normal but I think
one thing that will definitely change
will be maybe as its image Sandra said
like the the attitudes towards remote
working which I think it'd be quite a
positive thing and it might actually
like open up clients into a whole kind
of new cancer Porsche maybe they haven't
had access to before because they've
been really rigid on needs when the
office five days a week I need to see
them silver lining is this may be change
of kind of attitudes water as a whole
yeah yeah Sandra actually might make
hiring and some businesses and pretend
process is quick and moving great we've
had a number of client and recently and
so one kind recently and and they're on
board into you members of staff in April
they've offered and they spoke yeah and
it'd be nice that we can have a bit more
that moving forward I think all of you
guys who so I think it's interesting
right because I think there would have
been a lot of people that would have
been so like auntie work from home yeah
and but obviously going into this
there's no other options to light like
marriage for you for you for example
like before this if I was to say if I
work from home or in the office what
would you say I'd definitely office yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and so I think that's what's that nice I
love going in and seeing my team and I'm
gonna [ __ ] me before I get there yeah my
mother stood a school Berlin
you know Medtronic now out the door with
kids and yeah it's just great seeing
everyone and the banter that you get in
the office but we've always been really
open to home working before we input we
implemented four-day work and we kinda
last year but before we implemented that
and we allowed up to one day a week home
working have always been open to it
anyway but and I think majority of
people prefer being in the office
NIC office or home I've always had a
balance so you always buy used to spend
at least one day away from work so at
home I think I look forward to you know
rebalancing that what AM so as we sort
of finish it where where do we think the
sort of pockets of opportunities are
from what you're saying and maybe
specific to a sect or whatever but what
what on the sort of positive note where
do we think some of the opportunities
are that you're saying I'm actually
sundar you just said there that one you
clients is onboarding tibul April at
amazing but like where do we what was
sort of where the sort of pockets of
opportunity do we think all the things
that you're saying and picking up on to
go after tech within the healthcare
industry yeah of course if you if you in
tech 90 and and I'd also look at we
should do that we've never done that
before like would you literally try and
or mother that we're not specific to
Zach to really so yeah fair enough
mode technology equipment businesses ham
so yeah you can't you can and and also
remote companies that already
particularly tech businesses that
already operated remotely and it's
obviously they were they were already
onboarding remotely and doing reviews
and management meetings accessory
remotely so there'll be no difference
for those vows Mariusz where the sort of
pockets of opportunity you see no CEO of
surfing public sectors helped right yeah
yeah yeah I mean it's a it's a mixed bag
like um I guess that HMRC
example they've also got people build
the fellow portal yeah yeah absolutely
so I think it's AI just trying to think
about stuff like that and elearning
companies companies like zoom obviously
your online retailers like super marcus
that's some stuff hmm Nick you're in
real estate well I love know how many
marketing calls zoom got last has
everyone seen the solve the impacts and
what their stocks been worth or what the
shares have you seen that now on that
cross crazy it's in terms of the last
month or so the the amount that that
business is worth now or its increases
it's crazy yeah but Nick what pockets of
opportunity you have you saw were
identified or seen I think probably and
anything I would say we bit to real
estate it to sector focus but the one
thing I think a lot of our consultants
have realized is how open people are I'm
willing to help and and actually I think
that's always been a case we just
haven't always asked for their help and
so right now when you're working on
maybe fewer fewer jobs
make sure you enlist the help of every
client you've ever had every kind of it
you've ever spoken to to help you fill
those jobs by just asking them do you
this is what I've got
do you know anyone who was the best
person you've dealt with and I think
that will open up more doors for you
there as well because those clients will
perceive you then as not only being
busier than they expect is but then
valuing their opinion and they'll want
to come back and they'll want more of
that
mm-hmm also cornering Kennedy's hearts a
question before we finish so he's
looking to come into the recruitment
industry should he should he be trying
to get into industry right now away I'd
say like if you can find a company
that's um yeah this hiring people
I'd say join now because if you can but
everything goes glad to know we'd be
fine so yeah it could be a good time
ugly and now and if he joined now and
you
be one of those consultants that becomes
complacent least you can crack it now
you'll be very very successful yeah I
think I think this came up in one the
last ones when someone not sort of lost
this and I sort of made this all just
throw away common of yeah you haven't
been sort of build the best cars because
they've been in a little cream for a
really short pier and this has gone on
but one of the panelists really push
back and so actually this is probably
the best time you could burn your name
recruitment because the sort of
activities habits that you put into
place now on cultivate will help you
throughout the rest of your career
I think there's been loads of successful
recruitment businesses born out of the
Oh 8 recession and challenging times
like that
so Corner go through it I think what
we're saying in we give it a go and as
you come to the end here just want to
say a huge thanks to Marius Sondra Nick
have been very open been very honest
thank you for sharing and hopefully all
of you guys enjoyed that got value out
of it so thank you so much for and
joining us we'll be doing these also on
a weekly basis so if you enjoyed this
this will be here again next Wednesday
but just a huge thank you so thanks
again Mary Sandra and Nick thanks for
having us I'm gonna end this now